You know how the suffix "-core"
is all over the place?
Everything's "cottagecore"
or "goblincore"
or angelcore," or whatever,
but forty years ago,
we only had the word "hardcore,"
which referred to punk music
that was hard to the core
And that's important
because, in the 1980s,
the meaning of "core"
became dissociated from
"hard to the core"
and just began to refer to
musical aesthetics
like "gloomcore" or "speedcore"
At this point,
the word split into a new grammatical category
called a "bound suffix,"
which has to be attached to other words
A similar example is "verse,"
which split off from "universe"
to make words like "spiderverse" and "twitterverse"
Then the -core suffix
was increasingly abstracted
to refer to any aesthetic in general,
and this is where the algorithm comes in
by manufacturing extremely specific trends
Social media platforms directly incentivize
the creation of hyper-compartmentalized identities
like "grandmacore" or "fairycore,"
because they can then
curate commercialized content
that directly caters
to your new identity
and, in the process,
they keep you watching
while they sell you things
And this deliberate prioritization
of artificial microlabels
to build identity
is exactly how -core
became so popular
or -coded or -punk or -wave
it's all because we've been conditioned
into defining ourselves
in terms of very specific aesthetics